les cris de joie
et les larmes des partisans de Lula
pour beaucoup l'élection du Parti des
Travailleurs face à l'extrême droite et
plein de promesses
[Applaudissements]
à nouveau heureux
[Musique]
remporte l'élection présidentielle
l'ancien métallo de 77 ans accède à la
tête du pays pour la troisième fois mis
en prison pour corruption à l'issue de
ses premiers mandats il est libéré en
2019 pour vice de forme sa victoire du
jour signe une nouvelle page d'un destin
hors norme dans le camp de l'extrême
droite c'est la stupeur
jaillir bolsonaro a perdu avec un écart
de seulement 2 millions de voix sur 156
millions d'électeurs l'écart le plus
serré de l'histoire de la démocratie
brésilienne
soyons clairs les voyous qui étaient
présents ce week-end à Sainte-Soline se
fiche de la construction d'un bassin
l'ultra gauche est une tradition
française dans les années 70 c'était le
nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est le climat à
chaque fois c'est thème sont un prétexte
pour attaquer la société capitaliste
dans laquelle ses activistes ont tant de
mal à trouver leur place le Miss de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a parlé déco
terrorisme écoutez-le
les grandes gueules
on devait l'écouter géraldman il est
jamais parti le ministre de l'intérieur
on peut l'écouter
bon les plus de 1700 gendarmes qui dans
les Deux Sèvres ont maintenu l'ordre
républicain cela relève de l'éco
terrorisme il y a des gens qui fichent
c'est-à-dire radicalisé pour les
services de renseignement français pour
l'ultra gauche veulent le manifestement
le désordre et le chaos et de ne pouvons
l'accepter et qu'aux terrorisme un terme
rejeté en bloc ce matin par ces
militants qui occupent encore saint de
Soline nous ne sommes pas des écho
terroristes
nous sommes ceux qui protègent la
planète
a des deux côtés en plus
[Musique]
c'est un peu voilà
si vous le savez ce qui joue la division
en permanence
un moment donné ça gagne rien ça bonjour
vous êtes qui
on est
l'union de
ces gens-là tous ensemble pour lutter
contre des mêmes projets
vous étiez là il y a 5 ans mademoiselle
voilà
comment ça va patrouille mademoiselle je
suis pas de Mademoiselle alors comme toi
s'il te plaît
c'est par rapport à la stratégie du
cheval de Troie là je comprends mais par
contre fallait m'avertir Laura elle
s'est rajouté à la stratégie j'étais
même pas au courant de ça normalement
c'est moi qui gère la stratégie c'est
moi la stratagème dans l'histoire que
font ces jeunes filles masquées
etc voilà mais pourquoi donc c'est quand
même un peu à gauche elle a dit ce
qu'elles sont ultra gauche
c'est assez étonnant on voit bien
qu'elles ont 12 ans on est de l'ultra
gauche
Sandrine Rousseau qui a une nouvelle
fois défendu les mérites de la
déconstruction hier à la déconstruit la
conjugaison arriver à l'Assemblée
nationale le nuage de fumée des
incendies de Bordeaux nous avions la
gorge qui gratte nous avions les yeux
qui brûlons et nous votions à nous mais
la majorité et dès que les vents
souffleront nous en aurons belle hommage
involontaire à renoncer votre méthode a
permis l'éclosion d'un nouveau concept à
gauche celui de la motion de censure
inventable sorte de coït interrompu qui
permettrait d'aller au bout au bout du
discours sans conclure ça fait
maintenant 12 ans que Marie est ici elle
est mariée avec un norvégien il partage
la même passion pour les Vikings il se
battent mais ils s'aiment c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon s'il vous plaît ne
vous battez pas bonjour Marie
et femme se battent souvent Norvège
comme ça c'est une bonne thérapie de
couple une
pour nous de frenchies ils sont tombés
sur le chauffeur de taxi le plus patient
de Rome
[Musique]
le seul problème c'est son accent
tu as compris je le savais c'est dans le